* Mystische Klänge *
Gemeinsames Entspannen
im Klangbad in Auroville, Südindien.
Shivaya Ruth Hauser empfängt
Besucherinnen und Bewohner
im Unity Pavilion.
Was hat dich hierher gezogen?
Ich bin hierher gekommen, weil ich
von der Idee fasziniert war,
dass man so etwas wirklich probiert.
Und dass man sich von dem Utopischen an der Idee nicht abschrecken lässt.
Die Utopie in Südindien
feiert 50 Jahre.
Eingeladen sind seit 1968 Menschen
aus aller Welt, die den Willen haben,
ein Leben ohne Nation und Religion,
ohne Besitz und Hierarchien
zu versuchen.
Die sengende Sonne Tamil Nadus
setzt Ruth zu,
aber sie ist keine, die aufgibt.
Seit 37 Jahren lebt sie in Auroville.
Als Mitglied des inneren Zirkels
steuert sie diese selbstverwaltete
Gemeinschaft mit 2'700 Bewohnern mit.
Wer in Auroville arbeitet, bezieht
ein bescheidenes Grundeinkommen.
Im Gratis-Supermarkt
können die Bewohner holen,
was sie zum Leben brauchen.
Die Karotten sind organisch,
stammen aber nicht von unserer Farm.
Sondern sie kommen aus Ooty.
Sehen Sie, hier steht es.
Es gibt
kein offizielles Pensionsalter,
jeder arbeitet so lange, wie er mag.
You have a very good German.
These are people from the Swiss TV,
they want to make an emission.
(Lauter) Swiss TV.
- Ah, the Swiss TV! Okay.
Es ist eine Freude, hier zu leben.
Wir streiten nicht,
wir bombardieren uns nicht,
wir sind auf der Suche
nach dem göttlichen Bewusstsein.
Ein wunderbares Leben!
Kannst du dir vorstellen,
immer noch hier zu arbeiten,
wenn du so alt bist wie Don?
Wenn ich noch gesund bin,
fände ich das super.
D.h., man darf sich
dann so einbringen,
wie es für einen gut geht.
Arbeiten bedeutet hier ja auch,
an der Gemeinschaft teilzunehmen.
Es ist kein Müssen,
sondern eine Beteiligung.
Eine Contribution -
oder wie soll ich sagen?
Ein Beitrag zur Gemeinschaft.
Wer was mitnimmt, wird registriert.
Ein Leben ohne Geld, das war die
Vision der Gründerin von Auroville,
Mirra Alfassa.
Das Porträt der Mutter, wie sie
genannt wird, ist allgegenwärtig.
Hier verliebte sich Ruth
in einen Holländer,
der damals
in einer kleinen Hütte lebte.
Er wurde der Vater ihrer
beiden Kinder. Heute ist sie alleine.
Dass sie entschlossen war,
ihr Leben einer Utopie zu widmen,
forderte ihre Eltern heraus.
Meine Mutter konnte mich
irgendwie schon verstehen,
dass ich hier
bei etwas Neuem mitmachen wollte.
Mein Vater wollte es nicht wahrhaben
und nahm es mir sehr übel.
Aber als ich dann schwanger war
und in einer kleinen Hütte lebte,
fanden sie, dass ich doch
ein richtiges Haus bräuchte.
Ruth Hauser war auf der Suche
nach einem anderen Leben,
als sie mit 22
erstmals nach Indien reiste.
Auch, weil sie sich
vom Vater unterdrückt fühlte.
Dieses Haus selber zu bauen,
gab ihr Stärke.
Ich habe mir nicht viel zugetraut.
Diese Einstellung
kam sicher auch von zu Hause.
Mein Vater sagte mir immer,
ich könne und sei nichts.
Dies und das dürfe ich nicht tun,
jenes könne ich doch nicht machen,
und man solle nicht so tun.
Mit 25 zog die Lehrerin
von Chur nach Auroville.
Buchstäblich aus der Wüste
wuchs hier das Neue.
Der Versuch, eine Überzeugung
in die Tat umzusetzen, gefiel ihr.
Sie half mit beim Bau des
Matrimandir, des Meditationszentrums,
und beim Aufforsten
des abgeholzten Landes.
War das so eine Hippie-Community,
oder wie würdest du es beschreiben?
Ich würde es nicht
als Hippie-Gemeinschaft bezeichnen.
Es gab Hippies unter uns,
aber auch viele,
die vielleicht mal Hippies waren,
die dann aber aufhörten zu rauchen
und anderes sein liessen,
was zu den Hippies gehörte.
Und sie wandten sich
stark der inneren Suche zu.
Vom Vater der Kinder
hat sie sich früh getrennt.
Die Kinder hatten viel Freiheit
und Spielkameraden aus aller Welt.
Tochter Ladina lebt heute
wieder zeitweise in Auroville.
Sie hat in der Schweiz
eine Lehre als Coiffeuse gemacht.
Mit dem Geld der Eltern
baute Ruth ein grosszügiges Haus,
nicht nur für sich,
sondern für die Gemeinschaft.
Denn in Auroville
gibt es nur ein Wohnrecht,
Immobilien kann man nicht besitzen.
Für Ladina
war die Schweiz ein Kulturschock.
Das erste Mal
war wirklich schwierig.
V.a. weil es Winter war und ich zum ersten Mal für längere Zeit in einer so dunklen Umgebung war.
Ich war in Zürich,
wo es ziemlich viel Nebel hatte.
Das war für mich ziemlich ungewohnt.
Ich wurde ein bisschen depressiv
und wusste nicht wirklich, warum.
Ich habe auch bei einfachen Dingen
nicht verstanden,
wie sie funktionieren -
nur schon z.B. zur Post zu gehen.
Wie Ladina ging auch Ruth
manchmal in der Schweiz arbeiten.
Heute hat sie dank eines Erbes
mehr finanzielle Unabhängigkeit.
Mit dem Grundeinkommen
liegen keine Extras drin.
Gleich nebenan
wohnt Ladinas Bruder Kevin.
Er spricht nur Englisch,
die gemeinsame Sprache Aurovilles.
Ich liebe es hier.
Natürlich auch deswegen,
weil es mein Zuhause ist.
Aber ich war draussen, ich weiss,
wie der Rest der Welt ist.
Auroville hat schon Nachteile,
besonders weil es so klein ist.
Da ist für junge Leute
nicht viel los.
Darum gehen auch viele Junge raus,
etwa um zu studieren.
Ist es eine ideale Welt?
Nicht wirklich eine ideale Welt,
würde ich sagen.
Es gibt noch viel zu tun.
V.a. sind wir hier in Indien,
und da bist du mit vielem fast noch
stärker konfrontiert als in Europa.
Weil Indien so schnell
gewachsen ist, so viele Leute hat,
sieht man die negativen Seiten
der Konsumgesellschaft deutlich,
die mangelnde Sorge
für den Planeten.
Kevin fühlt sich wohl in der Utopie.
Was Ladina betrifft,
macht sich die Mutter mehr Gedanken.
Ruth, hattest du deinen Kindern gegenüber manchmal ein schlechtes Gewissen,
dass du ihnen das aufgezwungen hast?
Ja, solche Fragen
stellte ich mir ab und zu schon.
V.a. für Ladina
war es nicht immer einfach.
Da stellte sich
immer wieder die Frage,
ob sie hier oder in der Schweiz
leben möchte.
In die Schweiz zurückzugehen,
wäre sowieso schwierig.
Denn die Leute würden mich fragen,
woher ich eigentlich komme.
Wenn ich dann antworte,
ich käme aus Indien, sagen sie:
"Du siehst aber
nicht aus wie eine Inderin."
Und dann fragen die Leute,
ob das hier so eine Art Kult sei.
Eine Sekte.
- Ja, eine Sekte.
Was sagst du darauf?
Meistens sage ich ja ja.
Meistens sage ich das,
was sie hören wollen.
Geht es dir auch so, Ruth,
dass du vieles erklären musst,
wenn du in der Schweiz bist?
Früher sagte ich
wenig oder überhaupt nichts
über den spirituellen
oder den kollektiven Aspekt.
Ich sprach mehr
über die Aufforstung,
über die Arbeit mit dem Dorf,
wo ja viele soziale Projekte
realisiert werden,
bei denen ich z.T. mitgewirkt habe.
Und wenn die Leute
das dann besser verstanden,
fragten sie mich auch anderes.
Und dann erzählte ich auch mehr.
Für dich ist das Spirituelle wichtig?
- Natürlich ist das wichtig.
Auch die Ausrichtung
dieses Projekts,
ein Experiment einer neuen Form
des Lebens und des Zusammenlebens.
Als Gemeinschaft
ohne Hierarchien leben.
Hier im Rathaus von Auroville
arbeitet Ruth seit vielen Jahren
im inneren Rat mit, dem City Council.
Es herrscht Basisdemokratie,
d.h., es wird endlos diskutiert.
Die Sitzungen
dürfen wir nicht filmen,
weil nicht alle einverstanden sind.
Ein Blick ins Finanzbüro zeigt,
dass das Ideal der
multikulturellen Gesellschaft lebt.
Ungelöst aber ist in
der geldlosen Utopie das Thema Geld.
Intransparenz
begünstigt Eigennutz und Konflikte.
Ruth arbeitet mit an Lösungen.
Da müssen wir uns
immer wieder durchkämpfen.
Es geschieht
halt schon immer wieder,
dass die Leute dafür sorgen,
dass es ihnen am besten geht.
Sie überlegen,
wie sie es machen können,
damit sie
noch etwas mehr profitieren können
und es für sie und ihre Familie
gut ist.
Also Egoismus statt Gemeinsamkeit?
Ja, Egoismus versus Kollektiv
ist immer wieder ein Thema.
Wie lernen wir, wirklich umzudenken
und Vertrauen zu haben,
dass es mir dann auch gut geht,
wenn es allen gut geht?
An Geld für Wohnraum und Land
mangelt es.
Auroville konnte längst
noch nicht alles Land kaufen,
vom Stadtmodell
in Form eines Spiralnebels
ist man noch Galaxien weit entfernt.
Ruths Sohn Kevin ist Bauunternehmer.
Das Dilemma bringt er auf den Punkt.
Du kannst nicht hier leben
und arbeiten und genug verdienen,
um dir ein Haus zu kaufen.
Das Geld muss von woanders kommen.
Entweder du gehst raus,
um Geld zu verdienen,
oder du gründest eine Firma.
Aber das braucht Zeit,
bis du etabliert bist.
Mit seiner Firma verdient er
ausserhalb Aurovilles Geld.
Wer Gewinn macht,
sollte mind. einen Drittel davon
der Gemeinschaft abgeben.
Für solche Wohnungen
haben junge Leute zu wenig Geld.
Auroville ist jedoch dringend
auf junge Zuwanderer angewiesen.
Denn die Pioniere von einst
kommen ins Alter.
Doch für Junge ist Geld eine Hürde:
Wer nach Auroville ziehen möchte,
muss im ersten Jahr
12'000 $ bezahlen.
Deshalb hat Kevin nun Aufträge,
für junge Zuwanderer
kostenlose Unterkünfte zu bauen.
Er zeigt uns ein solches Projekt,
das er vor Kurzem fertiggestellt hat.
Das ist für Neuankömmlinge,
es ist temporär,
so dass sie wenigstens
etwas Einfaches zum Wohnen haben.
Auroville hat immer noch eine
grosse Anziehungskraft für Menschen,
die Dinge ausprobieren wollen.
Hier zeigt ein Fachmann
Interessierten,
wie man mit einfachsten Mitteln
ein Erdhaus baut.
Kevin lernte so von anderen Leuten,
aber auch viel von seinem Vater,
einem Schreiner.
Wenn die Arbeit in der Werkstatt
ruht, so wie jetzt, meditiert er oft
und befasst sich mit der Philosophie,
die hinter Auroville steht.
Wenn du hier aufwächst,
dann ist alles selbstverständlich.
Als Kind war das für mich etwas,
das die Oldies taten oder lasen.
Aber so langsam, wenn du
älter wirst, dann realisierst du,
dass da etwas dahintersteckt.
Es sind nicht einfach deine Eltern
auf irgendeinem Trip. Es sind Werte.
Du fängst selber an,
zu entdecken, worum es geht.
Für dich ist es also
mehr als ein Abenteuerspielplatz?
Sicher.
Es ist nicht gerade der Ort,
an dem du sein willst,
wenn du Unterhaltung suchst.
* Mystische Klänge *
Das Wahrzeichen und die Seele
von Auroville ist das Matrimandir,
die grosse Meditationshalle.
Es steht für die Suche
nach dem göttlichen Bewusstsein,
unabhängig von Religion.
Persönliche Entwicklung ist das Ziel.
Ein neuer Mensch
ohne Gier und ohne Angst.
* Meditationsgesang *
Sri Aurobindo, ein indischer
Freiheitskämpfer und Philosoph,
ist der geistige Vater von Auroville.
Um die Ideen Aurobindos
in die Tat umzusetzen,
gründete seine spirituelle
Weggefährtin 1968 Auroville.
Mirra Alfassa, genannt Mutter,
starb 1973.
Bis heute ist sie
der Kompass für die Utopie.
* Meditationsgesang *
Immer mehr Ausflügler
aus der nahen Stadt Pondicherry
entdecken die grüne Oase
mit internationalem Flair.
Sie zieht Touristen an,
aber auch Spekulanten.
Do you have any results
concerning the land?
Yes, we were actually looking
for a group of people ...
Geld sammeln für den Landkauf
ist wichtiger denn je,
damit Auroville den Boden
unter den Füssen nicht verliert.
It's great, super!
Von aussen besteht jetzt
viel Interesse am Projekt,
weil wir durch die Aufforstung und die ganze investierte Arbeit eine wunderschöne Insel aufgebaut haben.
Dadurch ist es natürlich
auch interessant für Leute,
die gerne davon profitieren möchten,
um Hotels oder Ähnliches zu bauen.
Setzte Auroville früher eher
auf Abschottung, versucht man nun,
die tamilischen Dörfer einzubeziehen.
Zuwanderer wie Ruth
werden als Fremde wahrgenommen.
Doch die tamilischen Aurovillianer -
gut 40 % der Bewohner -
wirken als Vermittler.
Sie setzen dabei auf die global
vernetzte, gut ausgebildete Jugend.
Ich sage immer: "Meine Kinder werden
einen grossen Unterschied machen."
Es wird sich verändern,
es wird viel besser sein als heute,
und zwar schon bald:
in vier, fünf Jahren.
Dann werden wir alle
das Spiel gemeinsam spielen.
Nicht nur Indien,
alles verändert sich.
Das weiss niemand besser
als Frederik, einer der Pioniere.
Er kannte die Gründerin Aurovilles
noch persönlich.
Heute ist das Abenteuer für ihn
ein ganz anderes als vor 50 Jahren.
Jede Organisation, die 50 Jahre alt
wird, hat die Tendenz zu verkrusten,
zu erstarren, ein System zu werden.
Heute schaust du mir
nicht mehr in die Augen,
sondern schreibst mir eine E-Mail.
Und du bist registriert.
Du lebst ja gar nicht,
du stehst nicht auf unserer Liste.
So ungefähr.
Das gab es damals gar nicht.
Das war ein bisschen
wie bei John Wayne.
Wir lebten in der Ranger-Zeit,
es gab keine Zäune,
nur die freie Prärie.
Und jetzt gibt es halt viele Zäune.
Darauf muss ich mich
ein bisschen neu einstellen.
Das ist ein Abenteuer für mich.
Da nicht zynisch zu werden
und in der Vergangenheit
hängen zu bleiben ...
"Damals, als wir gekommen
sind ...", das hört man ständig.
Ich finde, dazu passt
eine der Botschaften von Mutter:
Was ist "remain young"?
* Indische Sprechgesänge *
Hindu-Priester
weihen eine neue Strasse ein,
die indische Sponsoren
finanziert haben.
Ruth sieht das skeptisch.
Wir machen es ihnen zuliebe
in diesem indischen Rahmen.
Das machen wir nur ihretwegen.
Und das wird vielleicht
gar keinen guten Nachklang bringen.
Wieso?
Es soll ja ein Projekt sein,
und es ist ein Projekt,
das nicht religiös sein soll
oder sein will.
* Rhythmische Trommelschläge *
Die Schweizerin fühlt sich
in der Gemeinschaft aufgehoben.
Aber manchmal
sieht sie dunkle Wolken aufziehen.
Wo liegen persönlich
deine grössten Ängste?
Am meisten Angst macht mir
wahrscheinlich das heutige Indien.
Das ganze sehr aggressive Umfeld.
Und auch, wie Indien mit den grossen
Problemen wie Verschmutzung umgeht.
Ich sehe eine Art Verrohung.
Ich sage das so,
weil ich früher schon hier war,
als das Land noch sehr stark
mit dem Herzen regiert wurde.
Da habe ich den Eindruck,
dass der Kapitalismus
dem Land nicht gut bekommen ist.
Manche Kollegen hören es vielleicht
nicht gerne, was ich hier sage.
Aber es stimmt schon,
dass ich immer wieder dachte,
dass es schon gut ist, dass ich
einen Schweizer Pass besitze.
Auch wenn ich hierbleiben möchte
und mein ganzes Herz
in diesem Experiment verwurzelt ist,
ist es eine schöne Absicherung.
* Nachdenkliche, exotische Klänge *
37 Jahre ihres Lebens
hat sie für die Utopie eines
anderen Lebens gearbeitet und gelebt.
Hast du es nie bereut?
Bereut nicht,
aber ich hatte auch Phasen,
die schwierig waren.
Immer wieder.
Das gibt es in jedem Leben.
Die Welt scheint heute
von den Idealen Aurovilles
weiter weg denn je.
Doch Ruth lässt das nicht gelten.
Man sieht in dieser Welt ja
auch viele Zeichen des Kollapses.
Und gleichzeitig sieht man
überall auf der Welt Leute,
die genauso wie wir arbeiten,
vielleicht einfach
in kleineren Gruppen.
Oder mittels Medien oder Ähnlichem.
Wenn man genau hinschaut, sieht man,
dass eine Subkultur entsteht.
Und es geht darum,
das zu unterstützen.
Und ich denke, das ist
auch eine Rolle von Auroville.
Das Experiment Auroville lebt -
auch nach 50 Jahren.
Doch die Verwirklichung der Utopie
braucht vermutlich etwas länger.
Wenn wir damals jemanden wie Sri
Aurobindo oder Mutter gehabt hätten,
die mit uns gelebt hätten, wäre das
vielleicht viel schneller gegangen.
Wir sind bestimmt
viele Umwege gelaufen.
* Melancholischer Popsong:
"Imagine" von den Beatles *